le vol af 001 vient de se poser à
l'aéroport de roissy c'est le dernier
atterrissage d'un concorde d'air france
une dernière fois le grand oiseau blanc
remontent la piste ho pas sous les
applaudissements de milliers de curieux
dans l'avion supersonique 79 privilégiés
qui ont bouclé une dernière fois le new
york paris en trois heures trente
tous parlent de ce vol historique les
larmes aux yeux de l'émotion de la
vitesse et beaucoup de regrets qui va
disparaître c'était aussi la france qui
se promenait à travers le monde
jusqu'aux états unis
et puis l'accueil ici est extraordinaire
vous voyez les gens sur les routes sur
les pistes on se serait cru à une
formule heure où quelqu'un veut gagner
c'était le le sommet de la technologie
c'était une fierté une fierté d'avoir un
avion et je t'ai que par quelque chose
d'inaccessible parce que c'est ainsi
qu'il manque quelque chose qui est un
billet assez cher et il ya un mois et
demi quand j'ai appris que c'était la
fin j'ai tout fait pour pouvoir monter à
bord concorde a beau occuper une place à
part dans l'histoire mondiale de
l'aéronautique
c'était devenu un gouffre financier pour
air france et british airways
les deux compagnies qui l'exploitent
l'avion atteint un certain âge et n'est
plus possible ni économiquement ni
autrement d'envisager sa prolongation
donc nous sommes en train de clôturer
aussi dignement que possible une épopée
extraordinaire
l'appareil poursuivra ses vols
commerciaux chez british airways
jusqu'à fin octobre ensuite concorde
prendra sa retraite dans les grands
musées internationaux de l'aéronautique